sketchy sketchy is not a synonym for
destroying we're gonna do some drawing
today now don't worry
this circle is involved okay however the
second thing you notice is it's sketchy
Lydia grass that's every going to be
looking under this topic so far it's all
baited straight lines that's that's what
linear means line okay so you're gonna
need a ruler you cannot get away with
trying to draw it straight ish
it must be straight okay sir I have you
have to wait because uh yet what did you
so that's what we gonna do let's have a
look at the example now I'm gonna show
you two methods by the way this is all
about like in real life you always want
to have more than one way to do things
okay cuz sometimes one way is better
than another write out the equation y
equals two-thirds of X plus one and
we're gonna see what this looks like
okay the first method is using this this
equation using its like and its
intercept is actually short form
y-intercept all right so here we go
assuming you've already drawn your
beautiful set of axes there okay the
first thing you want to do is underneath
the equation that you've been given that
you should write W crazy well okay we
want to write it down then the
slope-intercept form of this equation we
write this for last lesson okay that
what you're looking at really right is y
equals MX plus B where there's a
specific end which is gradient and a
specific B which is the y-intercept okay
so you can see here you can actually
read it right here
that's M right that number there two
thirds okay and B is right here by the
way you'll notice I put it all the way
around a plus right cuz it's actually
important that it's plus one
- world - - you'd include the bogus site
as well okay so when you're drawing it
in you should do it the same way I have
right drew it all the way around the +
and the one together okay so okay so on
the basis of this I'm going to draw my
graph I'll start with the y-intercept
because really isn't okay the way two
scepters plus one right so here's the
y-axis and I want to just pick a point
you guys have got a grid in your books
mostly so maybe you want to got one or
two grid squares right
I don't so I'm just going to put it okay
now for me just personally to indicate
that this marker McGrath is not just any
old mark of the graph like maybe you've
got a whole bunch this mic is special
it's the y-intercept so to mark that out
I'll put an x over there like which
means you know I'm gonna go through this
point in a second okay great
we've done the way to set part of his
method now I get to do the slope pot now
slope gradient is another name for that
if you remember we've just noticed that
this Grady is up here it's the number in
front of the X the fancy word is it's
perfect audition okay it's two-thirds
the gradient or the slope equals two
over three
okay now do you remember what we'll try
to work out how do you we looked at how
to calculate a pretty yesterday we said
the slope or the gradient is it's
something over something do you know
what the things were yeah excellent
rise over run okay now when you have a
look at this fractionate we've seen in
the equation 2 over 3 that's the rise
and that's the run
run so here's how I'm going to use that
information right what I'll do is and
again you guys have got a grid which
make this so much easier
I'm gonna try it my best approximately
but you guys can do it precisely rise
over run two over three first thing is
I'm going to go up two units that's
that's the ride okay so I go up one two
so now I'm here along with three I've
risen to no no because remember my graph
is going to go through this point this
point here so that's why this is my
starting point glad you mentioned that a
boss time from zero I'm starting from
the blind intercept okay so then I rise
I go up two units okay from one up to
three so that's the right okay and since
I look like that I'm gonna run I'm gonna
go horizontally three years that's all
okay now like I said you guys have got
markings here I'm just gonna try it so
I'm gonna go across three they go okay
can you see I went up two and then I
went across three you see that up and
across and that there right that's gonna
be that Y that I'm gonna put through
this so now you get your ruler out again
okay effect I will and you're going to
join up these two points that's all you
have to do join up the two x's that
you've put on there my looks like this
okay there you go
the very last thing I'm going to do is
this line right it came from this
equation this is kind of like the line
of this equation right so I label it
with its equation and you finished okay
so that was a lot of different things so
let's write this down where did we start
okay I'll write down the steps for you
okay number one you prepared you
prepared by well we did things like we
drew a set of axes okay draw axes and
you also wrote down the equation you did
that just like I did okay and then what
you do is you we compared this equation
- why cause MX plus B and we saw all of
them and there's B okay so compare was
the verb right - y equals MX plus B and
the reason why is so we can work out
what M the gradient is and B the
y-intercept is right compared to this so
that
you can workout em which is the gradient
and B which is the one in descent okay
that was the second thing we did okay
now once we knew what M and B were what
was the next thing we do you remember I
plotted something yeah I plotted the
y-intercept right
so I said plot the y-intercept
now because it's a y-intercept we put it
on the y-axis right don't get them
confused why does that goes to the
y-axis so on the y axis which is the
vertical one okay I might write that in
for you
vertical one okay so we did the
y-intercept what did I do after that
yeah good excellent
so looked at rise over run I said look
if this here is the gradient that means
that's wrong and that's run in DOS mode
so then I went up and across
okay so then right what I do is I plot
another point that was this point let's
plot a second point using rise okay rise
and then run and like like tone notice
very well don't forget that you start
from this intercept right you know it's
not from zero you start from there go up
and across to start from y-intercept
I can't yet suppose no way that's
exactly right so if I had done these
earlier steps and I put my X in there
I'm gonna go through there then I would
go up from here and across exactly okay
1 2 3 4 the last it was we joined them a
lot okay connect the points join the
dots and that was the sketch